the day is january 5th 2012. at an
undisclosed off-site location dr bannon
leaves home and begins his commute to
work while in the car he plays a video
on his phone of his 12-year-old's
birthday party from the previous night
the side of it makes him smile he would
need that smile he thought as today was
not like any other today was different
he had been anxious about the coming day
for several weeks now ever since the
near unanimous vote by the o5 council
that the containment chamber of
scp-106 was to be reopened the
opportunity was too great to be wasted
they said the research that could be
gained too tempting studying
scp-106's molecular makeup its unique
ability to open a pocket dimension or
even just the black sludge-like
substance that appeared whenever the
subject traveled through solid objects
was far too valuable to science to be
outweighed by its potential for danger
he pleaded with them begged them but as
dr bannon and his team of seven
researchers and accompaniment of 40
security personnel began applying their
protective equipment he couldn't help
but think that he could have done more
to stop this only god knew how hard he
had tried to make them see reason he had
seen what had happened in previous
containment breaches at the facility he
had seen what had done to the poor
members of the scp staff that became its
victims fates worse than death limbs a
mangled mess of melted fused skin faces
sunken and hollow with eyes and tongues
burned out he shuddered to think of what
would happen if containment failed again
this time but despite his misgivings he
knew full well that regardless of his
participation this research mission
would go on with or without him and no
one knew as much about containing
scp-106
than he did slowly they proceeded to
dismantle each of the containment
facilities outer barriers 16 separate
circular chambers surrounded as cp-106's
inner containment facility each filled
with a variety of different fluids
fluids in each chamber varied in
consistency and viscosity from ionized
water to ammonia to kerosene
scp-106 had the peculiar ability to be
able to change its molecular makeup to
meld with objects and phase through
solid forms like walls and doors it
could literally melt into the space
between walls this made containing
scp-106 almost impossible by
conventional methods liquids confused
the creature enough to slow him down in
theory anyways the secondary containment
chambers were a recent addition to the
facility since the breach incident three
years ago dr bannon had been a new
addition to the research staff then he
had joined the team with bright eyes and
a desire to use their research to help
society little did he know he would
instead do everything in his power to
keep whatever they found from ever
leaving the facility back then a breach
in the containment of scp-106 led to
countless deaths of scp personnel when a
researcher working on the top floor of
the outer layer of the containment
facility unknowing of the danger they
were in brought his child to work one
day it was thought that the outer layers
of the facility were enough to be
considered a safe zone from the inner
vault that was as
cp-106's containment but it wasn't
enough to stop the old man
scp-106 preferred human prey between the
ages of 10 and 25 and the sound of a
child's cry or yell was enough to
capture its immediate attention what
preceded was unimaginable horror but
despite the unfortunate events of the
previous breach the expedition continued
their descent into the bowels of the
building after several hours of draining
individual fluid chambers one by one and
inputting complex codes and biometric
scans from simultaneous top security
clearance personnel at a time the
expedition team had eventually reached
the lower levels of
scp-106's containment facility suspended
in midair by eloid electromagnetic
support in the center of a vast
subterranean chamber was a massive
lead-lined steel cube 40 layers thick
each layer separated by 36 centimeters
of empty space with support struts
between layers randomly spaced to
confuse scp-106 from being able to phase
through one layer to the next
surrounding the cube on every surface
were military-grade automated light
systems capable of 80 000 lumens a piece
spaced every two feet around the
perimeter of the inner containment
chamber the team felt the resolve chip
away the closer they got to the
suspended creature dr bannon motioned to
overhead surveillance cameras above the
cube and waited slowly the cube was
lowered to the ground until it hit the
floor with a soft thud that lightly
rumbled the ground above the expedition
team's feet with a resentful look at the
red dot on the camera above dr bannon
initiated the release protocol all seven
researchers inputted their key cards and
submitted themselves to retina scans as
the 40 security personnel established
defensive positions on every side of the
lead line cube for a moment everyone
held their breath in silence you could
almost feel the thumping of everyone's
nervous heartbeats as they looked on to
dr bannon as he pulled out his key card
everyone knew that as soon as it was
scanned the barrier between them and the
old man would no longer exist if the
rest of the personnel could see bannon's
hand shaking as he gripped the key card
tightly between his fingers it would
cause a possible mass panic among the
whole team as the spear-heading
researcher on the job that day bannon
knew what he was up against just the
same as everyone else if not more he
knew he couldn't show the fear that was
pulsing through his veins this wasn't
his first rodeo here at the foundation
he took a moment to collect his thoughts
get a hold of yourself bannon he thought
dr bannon took a deep breath and scanned
the card the door slowly opened armed
with powerful rifle length flashlights
the researchers cautiously waded into
the dark entrance of the large cube
inside the structure they found a cell
with a solid steel door signs of
corrosion could be seen on the door's
handle and from the outer walls of the
cell rust and rotted iron but no
breaches in the integrity of the cell
there were no more security codes at
this door it was a simple round metal
turn lock dr bannon swallowed and began
to turn the handle open the sound of
metal echoed through the chamber as the
door creaked open each of the
researchers immediately pointed their
flashlights into the room there in the
corner standing motionless and
undisturbed stood
scp-106 the old man he stood with eyes
closed locked in a dormant state the
researchers had planned for this
scp-106 spent up to three months at a
time in this subdued state in between
periods of otherwise agitation where it
would lash out at its containment and
attempt to breach the research team
wasted no time they began to collect
data on the creature's biological makeup
taking whatever samples they could from
the walls and floors and recording photo
and video of the specimen while
collecting any method of conventional
analysis they could manage under the
given circumstances dr bannon kept an
eye on the old man's face the entire
time refusing to look away for one
second for fear of awaking in the
absence of his gaze but to his relief
the creature did not stir and the data
collection process went smoothly in a
short period of time the team had packed
their gear and proceeded to carefully
retreat from the inner chamber of the
cube making sure to keep their lights
pointed at the creature the entire time
once the team exited the steel-lined
cube they motioned again to the camera
and the huge heavy doors of the cube
closed back in on itself the
electromagnetic supports came back
online and the cube was suspended once
again in three-dimensional space without
any immediate contact with solid
surfaces the security detail began
packing up their positions as everyone
seemed to take a collective sigh of
relief that's when dr bannon noticed the
security camera the red dot on the
device had stopped blinking the camera
was off a sudden feeling of dread
entered dr bannon's stomach as he turned
in time to see all the cameras around
the room turning off before he could
react the chamber was plunged into
darkness as the electricity left the
room in the immediate darkness came a
deafening bang followed by a gust of
wind and the weight of a force strong
enough to shake the ground and knocked
the researchers off their feet the power
of the electromagnetic supports were
down the cube had fallen dr bannon
shouted to his team to immediately exit
the facility he reached for his
flashlight in the darkness he could hear
screams in the background gunfire he
managed to illuminate the space in front
of him and saw his molecular biologist
dr burns scrambling to get her gear back
up over her shoulder leave it dr bannon
cried only to see a hand emerge from
beneath her and pull her down into a
black viscous substance that swallowed
her whole and then vanished into solid
concrete after hearing the cries to his
left he swung his flashlight just in
time to see him the old man had its hand
on the chest of a security personnel and
entered him exiting through the other
side leaving a gaping hole in between
bullets were useless as they seemed to
get trapped on entry of his body slowly
melting into his skin
scp-106 then vanished into the floor and
appeared behind another member of the
security detail grabbing him by the heel
and dragging him as he pleaded and
reached out to dr bannon for help
pulling him halfway into the wall and
then letting go as the creature melted
into the space between the walls leaving
behind half the poor man's body bleeding
and still squirming to get away one by
one he could hear his researchers crying
out for help before their voices were
extinguished before he could think of
what to do next the power came back on
and lights flooded into the large room
he gazed at the creature as it stood
momentarily stunned by the influx of
light the old man had got piercing
hollow eyes in a face covered in dark
melting skin and a lipless mouth that
displayed terrible decaying teeth its
corrosive hand had a grasp on the arm of
dr breyer the physicist burning the skin
beneath its grip as he cried out in pain
and then without warning the creature
placed a hand on the wall of the metal
cube and disappeared into it pulling the
doctor in with him into the pocket
dimension between the walls 48 hours
later in containment site 19 located in
the state of
expunged scp personnel opened the door
to an observation chamber where scp-049
is let in wearing steel covered hand
restraints on the other side of the
glass panel dr blake sat impatiently
watching the humanoid creature known as
scp-049 the plague doctor take a seat
and face his direction dr blake
hesitated to address the entity that sat
in front of him but putting aside his
reservations he spoke into the
microphone blake informed scp-049 of the
recent breach that had transpired at the
scp-106 containment site the doctor
seemed intrigued at the news and when
asked if he would provide assistance the
doctor agreed
scp-049 had exhibited abilities to
produce instances of scp-049-2
reanimated corpses that he alone had the
ability to control by will in the past
the plague doctor had been allowed
certain privileges to cease subjects for
the doctor to experiment on in his quest
to finally cure for what he referred to
as the pestilence though none of the
researchers could pinpoint exactly what
the symptoms of this perceived illness
was or any specifics about it at all
however the supply of subjects was
halted after an incident where scp-049
struck a personnel member killing him
instantly with his touch of death an
ability that ceases all bodily function
upon contact since then the plague
doctor refused to cooperate unless he
was provided with live subjects for
experimentation up to this point he had
been denied but dr blake needed the
plague doctor's help and time was not on
his side dr blake agreed to provide
scp-049 with several live d-class
personnel in return for his assistance
as we've come to learn time and time
again here on scp explained the
foundation has no qualms about ridding
the lives of these ex-death row inmates
d-class are essentially the foundation's
lab rats and treating them as such is
more than worth it if dealing with an
scp-106
containment breach bring in the orange
jumpsuit splendid
remarked049 the plague doctor was taken
to the secret site of
scp-106's containment facility and
briefed on the old man's ability to meld
and travel between walls floors and
solid surfaces as well as its ability to
pull objects into its own pocket
dimension of which there was little
information about
scp-049 grew more and more intrigued by
the description of the old man upon
arriving a laboratory was prepared at
the site for scp-049
for proxies to serve as lures to bait
scp-106
the team procured the bodies of a recent
public transportation bus wreckage that
had left 12 younger adults dead as the
plague doctor began his surgeries on
them dr bannon could think only of the
prior containment breach the staff
suffered many casualties to personnel
and ever since then anyone under the age
of 30 were barred entry within 20 miles
of the containment site just as dr
bannon began to rub his temple to think
about how they managed to return scp-106
to his cell that day there was a yell of
excitement marvelous cried out scp-049
the plague doctor informed scp staff
that he had finished his work and the
surgeries had been of paramount success
the doctor had indeed produced 12
instances of
scp-049-2 as predicted the subjects were
horrid abominations some with inverted
faces and others with added appendages
and gaping holes where limbs should be
but they were ambient and the research
staff would soon learn if they would be
enough to lure scp-106
back into containment staring at the
dimly lit white room crowded with
malformed ambient corpses dr banning
couldn't help but feel a sense of dread
fill the pit of his stomach but there
was no time to second guess with rifles
and flashlights in hand the team led the
troop of
scp-049-2s out and down the concrete
hallways and into a large freight
elevator that led down to the vast
chamber that housed the inner
containment cube that was
scp-106's home since arriving at the
facility the drone-like-twos did not
speak during this trip they did not
blink they simply stared straight ahead
and acted at the behest of the plague
doctor without any verbal input the
macabre parade arrived at the entrance
of the cube and proceeded inside dr
bannon informed scp-049 that the d-2s
needed to make noises of some kind to
cry out if they could anything would
work as long as it was audible enough
the plague doctor nodded his head and
all 12 of the reanimated corpses began
to scream in terrifying unison in the
hollow distance a roar was heard in
response it dripped from the ceiling
first a drop then many more until a
puddle formed on the ground in front of
the cube the plague doctor approaching
with intrigue out of the floor rose up
the creature known as scp-106
coming face to face with the plague
doctor upon seeing the creature as
cp-049 was ecstatic he began to examine
scp-106 closely without fear of bodily
harm with lightning speed he produced a
vial and pinchers from a medicine bag of
black leather he kept under his robes
and snatched a sample of the creature's
black viscous skin the plague doctor was
overjoyed this will lead to my greatest
work and the cure for the pestilence
once and for all but the old man did not
seem to acknowledge or even enjoy the
presence of scp-049
and reacted violently lashing out to
strike the plague doctor sensing danger
049 jumped back and willed the 049-2s to
attack the creature but before they
could reach it
scp-106 melted into a pool of black and
disappeared into the floor the instances
looked around dazed another black pool
appeared under one of them causing it to
fall into the portal and then out from
the ceiling elsewhere in the vast
stadium-sized room another pool opened
up under one of the ambient thralls
sucking it down into the black abyss and
then another and another and soon loud
thuds could be heard echoing through the
chamber as bodies began to appear from
the top of the hundred foot ceiling
falling to a splatter on the concrete
floor below upon witnessing scp-106's
abilities first-hand
scp-049 nodded to dr bannon as he
swiftly packed up his medicine bag and
made for the door only to be blocked by
scp-106's materializing form the plague
doctor grew angry and struck the neck of
the old man with his cold touch of death
but it seemed to have no effect on
scp-106
the black substance on his body started
to creep over zero four nine's hand
sizzling and searing skin and flesh as
it went up the forearm sensing danger
the plague doctor pulled out a large
scalpel and in one quick motion sliced
off his own arm at the elbow the severed
limb fell to the floor engulfed by the
black bubbling substance
scp-106 then lunged at the doctor whose
quick agility allowed him to dodge and
make for the doorway once in the hall
scp-049 quickly pulled out a roll of
brown gauze from his medical bag and
began to wrap his bleeding wound tight
as he hurried through the dimly lit
corridor lights flickering on and off as
scp-049 turned a corner a black
substance appeared on the wall in front
of him and a chair came flying out of it
towards his head the doctor dodged it
but did not dodge a sharp metal spike
that materialized from another hole
appearing on the wall to his left it
pierced the outside of his knee causing
his movement to be slowed hearing the
sound of clanking metal the doctor
looked up in time to see a desk falling
out of another dimensional portal above
him he managed to roll sideways missing
the blow but straight into another one
of
scp-016's portals causing the doctor to
fall through the wall and into the floor
of the room below with a falling crash
the doctor landed in the lower room and
looked around quickly seeking to regain
his footing the old man was nowhere to
be seen but he could hear him bumping in
the darkness traveling through the walls
of the building the plague doctor
quickly analyzed the office room for
something useful on the wall he found a
map of the facility and studied the
schematics on the floor was a dead body
he crouched down close to it and stabbed
it with a syringe from his cloak
animating the corpse and commanding it
to run serving as a distraction to lead
scp-106 away so he could make it to the
adjoining hallway just a few hundred
feet away that was the armory limping
from his injured leg the plague doctor
waited for the old man to be led away as
he made it to the room he began tearing
through the weaponry that lined and
leaned up against the walls in every
direction ignoring the automatic rifles
as they were useless there he found what
he had been searching for flash grenades
as the form of another black portal
began to materialize in front of him he
pulled the pin and tossed the grenade in
that putrid puddle a blast of light
erupted from within followed by the
sound of the creature recoiling in pain
the plague doctor pulled another pin and
another and in this manner he led
scp-106 toward the secondary containment
facilities that had begun filling with
fluid when he reached a level where he
could recognize the smell of kerosene he
stopped there he waited as scp-106
emerged from the darkness in front of
him it snarled and howled spitting black
bits of tar as its gnarled yellow teeth
came close to the plague doctor's face
the plague doctor calmly turned and
waited out of the half-filled room as
cp-106 tried to lunge at him to follow
but it could not it found itself rooted
in liquid unable to easily open a portal
in the space between the walls stepping
out of the room the plague doctor
reached into his cloak and pulled out a
large match from his leather bag without
glancing back he struck the match and
gave a ginger toss into the flames
sliding the door closed behind him the
resulting explosion and subsequent
inferno damaged the walls of the
secondary containment facility and
caused significant seismic activity
within the outer walls of the
containment site emergency lights
flickered on and off in the darkness and
debris rained down from the ceiling in
every direction in this haze of rubble
the plague doctor picked himself up off
the ground and began to dust his cloak
clean with the one hand he had left
satisfied he took a content sigh and
began to make for the exit to the
outside world where he would resume his
quest to rid the earth of the pestilence
that had plagued mankind though an
unexpected surprise made him pause a
flaming corpse began to emerge from a
black hole in the wall beside him
scp-106 in intact and whole the flame
slowly seeping into his skin until they
were all extinguished and only smoke
rose from his body this time the doctor
was not so fast to react the creature
grabbed him by the face and slammed it
into the nearby wall cracking the marble
surface the black substance pulled
around the plague doctor's face
scp-106 opened a portal in the wall
pushing the doctor's head into it the
events that followed afterwards are
difficult to put together as camera
footage from the facility suffered
severe damage due to scp-049's explosion
of the secondary containment chambers
scp-106 was found back inside a cell in
the containment cube back to his dormant
state where he would remain again for
the next few months that is until he
would feel the need to hunt prey once
again as the doors of the 40-layer steel
cube closed the electromagnetic supports
came back online and the fluid chambers
repaired and refilled the committee is
currently voting on whether or not to
allow
scp-106's containment facility to be
opened again for now the world could
rest once more dr bannon could take a
sigh of relief but for how long he
thought for that there was no way to
tell now go check out scp-049 the plague
doctor captured and scp-106 the old man
escape for more tales about your
favorite anomalous entities from scp
explained